Speaker 1: Very briefly, I do want to have as an
interlude here, it was a very weird day for Elon
Musk on Election Day. Musk shared a Nazi meme
to Twitter and then told his followers to vote
for Republicans. Not a particularly normal day.
Ali Quinlan Hough telling writing a good summary
of this in The Daily Beast. Elon Musk posting a
How Times have changed meme to Twitter. This got
43,000 retweets and 180,000 likes in a couple
hours. It's a Nazi meme. It uses a photo of a
German soldier with a cage of carrier pigeons
during the Nazi invasion of France. It had about
14,000 retweets in the 3
hours after it was posted.
And so. That was sort of a weird thing to do.
And then Elon Musk suggested on Twitter that
everybody vote Republican. Elon Musk saying to
independent minded voters, shared power curbs
the worst excesses of both parties. Therefore,
I recommend voting for a Republican Congress
given that the presidency is Democratic. This
is very, very stupid. And I will tell you why.
Even if in the abstract you believe that absolute
power corrupts people? Absolutely. You have to
consider what we're talking about. Even when
controlling the White House, House and Senate
Republicans still have extraordinarily
when when Democrats control those three.
Republicans have shown they have extraordinary
power to obstruct the things Joe Biden wants to
do. Most things require 60 votes in the Senate.
Democrats have not had a supermajority, and as a
result, everything has been a fight for Democrats.
The idea that Democrats have had basically carte
blanche to do whatever they want is untrue. So
the framing of this idea is untrue. Furthermore,
divided power isn't good. Just for its own sake.
If the people that would hold some of that power
have no business doing so. People like Herschel
Walker. People like Mehmet Oz, governors like
Doug Mastriano or Kerry Lake. And so this is the
prototypical what I call enlightened centrist type
posts. Elon Musk likes to say I'm an independent.
I've mostly voted for Democrats up until this
year. Now, I suggest voting Republicans because we
want you know, they're both the same and we've got
to divide power and bah bah, bah, bah, bah. This
is the prototypical, prototypical, enlightened,
centrist type argument. It is nonsense.
And fortunately, there was no red wave.